hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreign again coming to
you again live from this backseat of my
car
as usual I only got a couple more
classes of me to go through with this so
eventually I'll be back in my studio or
in my basement again but we always got
to get these warriors then it's done you
know how it is now it's actually pretty
nice because it's the 100th episode of
the Warriors then and it's also the year
2 anniversary all for honor now I've
been covering this for a pretty long
time I haven't covered every single
warriors down like the beginning the
beginning ones but I'm at least on like
number 98 or something so that's a lot
of videos regarding the Dead stream but
for some quick info because there was
really not much to talk about today
since it was more of a celebration that
the skill meter in the game is cruelly
broken we already know this it'll save
the skills on par and it only says on
par regardless of who you're fighting so
it's been removed so that they can do a
quick maintenance patch of it but being
a maintenance in patch there was one
released I believe yesterday and this
one had a few changes through goki and
black prior they weren't really big it
was just some bug fixes so there wasn't
really anything monumental so nothing to
be worried about next up as usual
there's a new arcade quest if you want
to attempt that and get the new season 9
plasma pink shock effect and there's
also a new event order for the weekend
to be the faction with the most amount
of matches completed and the award is
going to be scavenger crates now also
the new content of the week is going to
be the house champion mythic outfit that
comes with the firework effect it's
gonna be discounted at ten thousand
steel and it will only be available from
today until the 21st of February so get
it while you can because if we do not
get to provide the 21st of February it's
going to be gone and probably won't be
back for another year very exciting
because I'm actually a really big fan of
the house champion mythic outfits
personally one of my favorite effects so
and especially because it's a it's a
it's been in the game for a long time
but it's very limited so I'm not too
many people have it so if you do want to
go grab that definite go get it while
you can it's ten thousand steal as for
the rest of the stream it was just the
celebration of the past two years they
showed fan art talked about the history
of the game brought back a meal and a
super old face in the community if you
watch the old warrior stands like myself
he hasn't been on the streams in like Oh
more than a year so that was really cool
to see him they brought on Roman as well
he's been around in the background doing
some other stuff since he's I believe
like the senior director and I also
brought a cosplayer named pan who ended
up they ended up just inhaling helium
with so that was pretty interesting to
watch
Wow is it working everybody warriors day
and then lastly probably the saddest
thing I've ever heard in my entire life
is that Eric Pope will be leaving the
Warriors then soon because he found a
lot of huge projects he can help with
within Ubisoft so congrats to him so
just like what we did with Damian in my
comments like should we get an F for the
big man at home me Eric in the chat
please eric has been helping out on the
Warriors then since the beginning I
appreciate all the hard work he's done
for the community so if we can get a
quick effing chat for my main man Eric
would be greatly appreciated if we do
enjoy subscriber for new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being bounced into sphere updates
patrons and links you know get caught up
today with everything happening in the
world of foreigners who never miss out
what's happening definitely stay
subscribe to the channel like that guys
my two most recent videos will be on the
screen if you guys do want to check that
out when I got took greatest today I
thank for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]
you